bonjour à tous et merci de vous joindre
à nous bonjour édition spéciale consacré
presque essentiellement à la tempête qui
a traversé la france il ya la marée
noire qui continue d'arriver sur les
côtes atlantiques la sécurité civile
annonce un bilan provisoire d'au moins
33 morts après le passage hier d'une
tempête qualifiée d'historique et
d'exceptionnel sur la moitié nord du
pays
le plan sac a été déclenché dans cinq
départements de l'est de la france
nous allons faire un tour complet de la
situation en commençant par la région
parisienne l'une de nos équipes a
survolé en fin de matinée l'île de
france pour constater l'étendue des
dégâts reportage patrick fandio avec
raymond chaplin et jean françois chevet
au cirque le spectacle allait débuter
dans quelques jours
mais ce matin déjà c'est un spectacle de
désolation les chapiteaux de la pelouse
de reuilly n'ont pas résisté à la
puissance du vous plus loin c'est une
grue géante qui est tombée sur un
chantier à la sortie de vincennes pour
bois de boulogne
les arbres se sont couchés les uns après
les autres en deux heures et
spécialistes appellent ça les fait
château de cartes il estime à un million
le nombre d'arbres renversés dans toutes
les forêts en ile-de-france renversé
souvent sur les autoroutes qui longent
les forêts comme ici sur l'a13 sur le
tronçon orgeval reprend pour plus de 200
arbres jonchent la chaussée
l'autoroute est fermée dans les deux
sens
depuis hier soir à la tronçonneuse les
pompiers dégage les voies
ce matin ils ont dû faire appel à la
gendarmerie
trois blindés sont arrivés en renfort
et enfin procéder aux opérations de
balayage est également empreint de
secteurs servir encore faut il les
arbres qui menacent encore de se battre
pour qu'ils risquent de tomber sur les
quatre voies de circulation
donc il faudra élaguer ces arbres là
profitez bien sûr qu'une forte sur des
automobilistes et rahou verture probable
de ce sens de circulation à 13 sens
province probablement en fin de matinée
les travaux de dégagement pris du retard
il devrait durer une bonne partie de la
journée en venant de l'ouest
les automobilistes peuvent emprunter
l'a14 exceptionnellement gratuite pour
un lendemain de tempête elle aussi
exceptionnelle